hi I'm Fergus early a product manager at
Google tyro testing is an essential part
of building a high quality app or game
but the process can be time-consuming
and frustrating
that's why we've added new features to a
pre-launch report to make basic app
testing a breeze
so what is the pre-launch board it's a
helpful dashboard within the Google Play
console that alerts you of any quality
concerns in your app before it affects
your users whenever you upload an app to
the closed or open testing tracks in the
Google Play console you'll automatically
generate this free report the report is
created from an automated crawl if your
app using the tools and infrastructure
of firebase sets up their caller which
we call Robo explores your app by
inputting taps swipes and text tests are
on and a wide range of devices a varying
specs and price points once your app has
been crawled within an hour the
pre-launch report Flags any crashes
security vulnerabilities startup time
issues are other problems on the
overview page you'll find clear
recommendations on how to address the
results you also see a summary of the
issues found by the crawler it even
offers suggestions of taking advantage
of the reports more advanced features
we'll come back to that in a moment
below that you'll see the full details
of everything in the crawler found
including screenshots and videos taken
during the crawl these are great for
spotting UX issues are seeing what the
caller was doing when your app crashed
we've also added information about
accessibility and usability issues like
small touch targets poor contrast and
missing are confusing voice annotations
while the pre-launch report is useful in
its default State you can easily
customize it to focus on the things that
matter most to your app for example what
robot can crawl any app built on the
android framework what if your app our
game uses OpenGL in that case you can
use demo loops or monkey actions a demo
loop lets you create automated journeys
true your app so if you're testing a
game you might configure it to focus on
a particular level or a character to run
a demo loop first add the loop to your
game they modify your game to launch and
run the demo loop
declared the demo loop in your apps
manifesto now when you run a test the
Koala will use the demo loop when the
caller is finished you'll see both the
standard test results and any rendering
issues so you can investigate any
problems with frame rates a monkey
action let's our crawler test actions in
places where you haven't provided Emma
Luke in this case when the crawler
reaches an open jail canvas it will
perform random taps and swipes well it
doesn't have the sophistication of a
demo loop it can detect issues
you didn't encounter in your test and
what if your app asks for users to sign
in no problem the crawler can test that
logged in experience too if you use
sign-in with Google the crawler can
locate the login button and use the
Google account that's already included
on the test device if your app uses a
custom sign-in mechanism just configure
the pre-launch report with a test
account go to settings and enter the
resources used for the username and
password fields as well as the login
button you'll also enter the test
username and password
now when the crawler encounters your
login button you'll enter the test
account details and keep testing the
pre-launch report can also test up to 3
deep links deep links take users right
to the specific feature in your app
skipping the usual entry flow to specify
which deep links you want to test go to
the settings and just add the URLs the
crawler will run for about five minutes
then close your app and visit each deep
link for about 30 seconds each if it
finds any issues you'll see them in the
report
what if you want even more control maybe
your app has a sign-up screen early in
the onboarding flow that you need to
test are you want the crawler to
exercise a specific part of your app
that's where Robo scripts come in Robo
scripts are a sequence of actions
recorded a JSON file to record a script
open Android studio go to tools and open
firebase click record Robo script and
use it to guide Robo test then record
Robo script select the test device and
record the steps you want to the caller
to follow and save the role with script
file now go to the pre-launch report and
upload your script under settings the
next time you run the crawler it'll open
your robo script and follow the sequence
of steps you recorded before returning
to its default crawling pattern the
pre-launch report can also be configured
to test in any language by default it
will test the most popular languages
among your users but you may want to
test out a new version before launching
it with a new language to test in
another language open the pre-launch
port settings anytime after the initial
crawl of your app you can define up to
five languages to test when you upload a
new version the pre-launch port is a
great way to do a final quality check
after your own QA testing helping you
deliver higher quality apps and games
everyone who publishes a BK's to the
closed or open testing tracks can get a
free launch report just open the Google
Play console to get your free report
check it out next time you're uploading
a pre-production app thanks for watching